gabby and her fiance embarked on a
cross-country trip in gabby's 2012 white
ford band
it was like every parent's nightmare
just like in a flash of a second that
she got she's missing
step back and breathe
the thoughts that were going through my
head were something something really bad
has happened to her
that time when we were looking for gabby
where's
that's blur
it's really wicked
it's horrific
the media and the internet just went
crazy i think the hashtag find gabby hit
like over a billion people her bright
beautiful light touched a lot of people
i am going to walk down here a little
bit because i see something
right here
okay is where they think that it's a
shadow of someone digging there was
definitely more to this relationship
than was being shown on social media
so a body has been found
in the area that they were searching for
gabby potato it's still unbelievable i
don't understand that this is all i have
left now
i really don't know what justice for
gabby looks like at this point
everybody deserves to feel safe at home
everybody deserves to be found that is
missing
everyone
you